- [Voiceover] We've
already seen one definition
of the definite integral, and many of them
are closely related to this definition
that we've already seen
is the definite integral
from a to b of f of x d
of x is this area shaded
in blue, and we can approximate it
by splitting it into n rectangles.
So let's say that's the
first rectangle, one.
That's the second
rectangle, two, and you're
going to go all the way
to the nth rectangle,
so this would be the n
minus oneth rectangle.
For the sake of this
argument I'm going to make
in this video, we're going to assume
that they're all the same width.
So this is the nth rectangle.
They all have the same
width, and we see they're
definitions of integration
where you don't have
to have the same width here, but let's say
that each of those widths are delta x,
and the way that we
calculate delta x is we take
b minus a and we divide it by n,
which is common sense, or this is
what you learned in division.
We're just taking this
length and dividing it
by n to get n equals spacings of delta x.
So if you do this, you'll say, okay,
well we see this multiple times,
you can approximate it.
You can approximate this
area using these rectangles
as the sum from i equals one to n.
So you're summing n of
these rectangle's areas
where the height of
each of these rectangles
are going to be f of
x sub i, where x sub i
is the point at which
you're taking the function
value to find out its height.
So that could be x of
one, x of two, x of three,
so on and so forth, and
you're multiplying that
times your delta x.
So you take x sub two, f of x sub two
is that height right there.
You multiply it times delta x.
You get the area.
We saw that when we looked at Riemann sums
and using that to approximate.
We said, hey the one definition
of the definite integral
is that since this is
the area this is going
to be the limit as n approaches infinity
of this where delta x is defined as that.
So let me just copy and paste that.
So that's one way to think about it.
Now, given this definition,
what do you think
this, or maybe another
way to think about it,
how do you think this
expression that I'm writing
right over here based on this definition
should relate to this expression?
So notice, all I've done
is I've segued from a to b.
I'm now going from b to a.
How do you think these
two things should relate?
I encourage you to look at all of this
to come to that conclusion,
and pause the video to do so.
Well let's just think about
what's going to happen.
This is going to be,
if I were to literally
just take this and copy
and paste it, which is
exactly what I'm going to
do, if I just took this,
by definition, since I
swapped these two bounds,
I'm going to want to swap these two.
Instead of b minus a it's
going to be a minus b now.
It's going to be a minus b.
This value right over here.
Let me make these color-coded maybe.
So this orange delta x is
going to be the negative
of this green delta x.
This is the negative of
that right over there,
and everything else is the same.
So what am I going to end up doing?
Well I'm essentially
going to end up having
the negative value of this.
So this is going to be
equal to the negative
of the integral from a to b of f of x dx.
So this is the result
we get, which is another
really important integration property,
that if you swap the
bounds of integration,
and it really just comes from this idea,
instead of delta x being
b minus a, if you swap
the bounds of integration,
it's going to be a minus b.
We're going to get the negative delta x,
or the negative of your original delta x,
which is going to give you the negative
of this original value right over here.
Once again, this is a
really, really useful
integration property where you're trying
to make sense of some integrals and even
sometimes solve some of them.